Good afternoon. Today
we're going to talk
about the musculoskeletal
system and the
imaging of the
musculoskeletal system.
Here are the objectives.
This, I don't think
you need to be a
radiologist to realize
that this is abnormal. The
hip should not live
outside the body. It
should be over here
at the glenoid and the
acetabular fossa, same
as the other side.
And that there's
a proximal
femoral fracture
over here.
This is an example
of an open fracture,
which we'll talk
about later on.
So the most
important thing is
having a systematic
approach.
One, we want to
identify the body part.
That's probably the
most important thing.
There should be
a minimum of two
views, a frontal and
nonal view. So two
views are orthogonal
to each other.
Most joints will
have an oblique view
related to as well. We
also want to know if
the patient's an adult
or child because your
differential change
based on the age of
the patient. So if I
see a lesion in the
patient that's a pediatric
patient, my first
differential is not
metastatic disease.
It would be more of
a primary bone tumor.
So anything in red
is very important to
know on these power
points, something
you may see in life
that you should do
in real life, as
well as see in exams.
So one, we're going to
check the alignment.
Two, we're going
to evaluate
for joint spaces.
Then we're going
to evaluate the
bone cortex.
And then lastly,
we're going to
evaluate the soft
tissue structures.
This is just describing
the different x-ray
densities from darkest
to lightest, with
darkest being air and
the lightest being
metal, such as this
person with the AICD
and the darkest being
the gas in the lungs.
So joint alignment,
loss of alignment
may be due to
a fracture or
dislocation. So what
we're going to do is
we're going to
trace each of these
bones and make sure
that they align.
And then we can see
when we get to the
third metatarsal,
the metatarsal filial
angel joint, they
are not aligned. So
this is an example
of a dislocation. So
these all align, but
this one does not.
You may say, well, this
looks a little crooked
to me. Well, that
is true because they
have a bunion deformity.
or how's valgus
deforming and this little
bones over here are
called sesamoid bones
which you'll see on
x-rays they occur where
tendons tendons curve
so the patella is
technically a sesamoid
so once again something
in red very important
to know here's your
humeral head is
located anterior to
the glenoid so this is
anterior glenohumeral
dislocation this is the
normal appearance
of the humeral head
articulates with the
glenoid here's a wide view
or a lateral view looking
at that same thing.
So here's the glenoid,
here's your coracoid
process, here's your
hermoral head. So
this is anterior
glenohemal dislocation.
This is what it normally
should look like. It
should normally sit
in the glenoid fossa.
Then we talk about
the joint spaces. Are
they narrowed, which
may be due to cartilage
loss, or they'd be
widened or destroyed
due to a dislocation
or dissociation.
So when we're looking,
we can look at
all the other joints.
We can see that
there's a nice space
between them. But
when we get to the
first maritossal, we
can see that there's
a mark loss of space
to it, and they develop
some buttressing
osteophytes. So
this is arthritis of
that first myrtosal
phalangeal joint.
Next, very important
that I have all the
residents do is trace
the cortices. You want
to trace every single
cortex to the bone.
Each of this white
line is the cortex,
and it should be
traced entirely on
every single bone that
you're looking at.
You can see here,
when we come across
tracing the cortex,
there is a gap in that
cortex. so this is an
example of a fracture
well you have to make
sure you trace every
single bone for
any breaches of the
cortex which indicate a
fracture because often
fractures occur
multiple so you want to
make sure that there
is not multiple
fractures you're missing
just because you saw
one this is an important
finding to know
this is not a fracture
this is a nutriophoramina
occurs in the long
bones the femur
and the humerus at
the level of mid
-diathesis it's normal.
It's a normal variant.
I'll just call it
a neutropharma,
not to be mistaken
for a fracture.
One of the things
we're gonna look at
is the soft tissues.
So when we're looking
at the soft tissues,
we can look for
is there joint
infusion or not, or is
there a soft tissue
spawning. So those
are the things that
you want to look
at. So this here,
here's your patella.
Over here, here is
Here's your distal
femur, here's
your tibia and
fibula, here's your
patellar, tibia
and quadraten.
This over here is
a joint infusion,
it's your
supatella bursa.
So, the joint
infusions may indicate
that there's
pathology in the
joint that we may
not normally see.
So what happens is, on
this view here, this
joint infusion is what
we call a lipoenium
arthrosis. They have
fat and fluid in
the joint. And the reason
why is because they
have a fracture of
the proximal tibia.
and this fracture goes
to the level of the
joint the fat is known
there's normal marrow
in the bone normal
bone marrow has fat
so anytime you have a
breach of the cortex
that fat can link out
to the joint and you
get a fat fluid level
or lymphoma arthrosis
so you think of oil
and water on a lateral
view the oil is
gonna float on top of
the water so that causes
that fat fluid level
this is a very important
picture to know
how going forward
you're looking at this
so what's the principle
of viewing joints
or extremities you
need at least two views
and don't get
satisfaction in search you
need at least two views
because you may miss
something they need
to be 90 degrees for
each other so here's an
example here's a frontal
view of the ankle
tibia fibula talus so
two views if i told you
there's a fractionist
view you may tell
me where but when i
showed you the orthogonal
view this fraction
of the fibula is very
obvious now Not here,
it was right here
before, but now it's very
obvious because
there's two views. The
reason why that happens
is because X-rays were
coming in and were
directly in line with
the level, the path of
the fracture itself.
So you need two views,
many of them are
orthogonal to each other.
Same thing applies
in this case. So I
told you there's a
dislocation of the wrist,
you may be like,
well, where do I see
the dislocation? I'm
not exactly sure.
And then when we
look at the lateral
view, we can see
that the lunate is
dislocated boldly.
So this is a
lunatic dislocation.
Easier to see on
the loud view than
the frontal view.
And you can always
compare sides. So
here's the normal left
femur. This is the
abnormal femur on
this side. So we can
see that there's
loosens in the femur
over here. So this is
a femoral fracture.
So it's always nice
to compare sides.
And then don't
get satisfaction
searched. Don't get
satisfied with what
you find initially.
Make sure you
evaluate every single
bone structure.
and soft tissue
structure. So your eyes
are probably drawn to
this big calcification
pose, which is an
incidental calcified
fibroid or Lyme armous
uterus with degeneration
calcification. But
you may have missed
that there is a femoral
fracture on this
side with this lucency.
Here's the normal
femoral neck, lucency
in this femoral
neck. Don't get
distracted by the fibroid.
As a radiologist,
we're responsible
for everything in
the film, so we will
trace all these
cortices. We'll look
at all the joints
and the bones, but
also we're responsible
for the lungs.
So in this person has
nice dark lungs over
here. This person has
a having radiculopathy
type symptoms on
their arm. Turns out
they have a large
Panko's tumor, which is
causing those symptoms.
So we are evaluate
for everything. So
always evaluate the
whole film and don't
get satisfied research.
It's also hard to
see what's not there.
This person had a
resection of a bone, well
you may have to repeat
that mnemonic for
the carpal bones in
your head, but the
trapezium was resected
over here because
the trapezium articulates
with the thumb,
and what they did was
they put a hardware
in there. Here's a
end plate, a plate,
and they put a tension
wire between the two
of them because they
resected this bone,
but it may be hard
to see that the bone
is resected if you
don't know it's there.
Same thing here.
We don't see the
superior superior *****
ramus on this side,
we see a little bit
on this side, but it's
always hard to see
what's not there.
This happens to be a
superior ***** ramus
lesion that's being
averted by a large
tumor that averted it.
Next, we're going to talk
about fracture
descriptions.
There are different
fracture descriptions,
and I'm not going
to hold you to any
of those on exams,
but you should know
about them in real
life. The transverse,
are they bleak,
spiral, longitudinal?
Are the fractures
displaced or angulated?
Are there multiple
fracture fragments,
and do they involve
the articular surface?
A couple of
things to note. We
spoke about
open fractures
really briefly
in the beginning.
An open fracture is
when it's exposed to
air. So the bone either
violated the soft
tissues, or the
laceration in the soft
tissues violated
down to the bone. So
those are the ones
that are surgical
emergencies that need
to be washed out because
you get an increased
risk of infection.
And then there's
pathologic
fractures. There's
two different
types of pathologic
fracture.
Pathologic fracture
can be caused
of normal stress
on the abnormal
bone. Is there a
bone tumor underneath
it or the patient's
osteopenic?
Or a pathologic
fracture could have
abnormal stress on
the normal bone, such
as your stress
fractures. Your runners
will get that. So
abnormal stress on
the normal bone is
a stress fracture.
pathologic
fracture is normal
stress and abnormal bone.
This is just the
schematic of the
different type of
fractures you may see
when you're in your
clinical practice.
This is an important
fracture to know
in kids. You're
going to see this in
the important know
for example. This is
the example of a
green fracture. We
have fracture on one
side of the bone and
just sort of buckling
and bending on
the other side of
the bone over here.
Here's an example of
stress fracture so
patient was having pain
pain they're walking
constantly have pain
they come in radiographs
but this is initially
when they saw the doctor
the doctor had then
come back and they
developed after they were
still having pain with
their walking about
14 days later and we
can see over here that
this fluffy stuff next
to the bone over here
this is what peri
-austral reaction looks
like and the reason why
you get developed peri
-austral reaction which
happens about 7 to 14
days after the insult,
is because the bone
is trying to heal
itself from the outside
in, so it develops this
periocity of new
bone. And this is what
you're going to see. So
this is an example of
a stress fracture. It
actually is called the
marsh fracture, which
you see in soldiers.
You will see these
changes in MRI first.
So if someone comes
with foot pain, you're
worried about stress
fracture, you do an
MRI, you're going
to see before the
periocity of new bone
develops, you're going
to see that the bone
marrow edema in there,
because the bone is
swollen and inflamed.
So you're going to
see that in the MRI.
We're going to
talk very briefly
about bone tumors,
and I'll highlight
what things I think
you should know.
So when something has a
geographic appearance,
it has a well-defined
appearance to it,
these are typically
benign or slow-growing,
where you can trace
a pencil around it.
So I can outline
this with the pencil.
So that is a benign,
slow-growing tumor.
it has a sclerotic
rim because the
bone has a chance to
remodel around it.
So it has about a
95% chance of being
benign when you see
something like this.
More aggressive type
lesions, which grow
more rapidly, you will
not see that cortical
rim and you know
may have a smoother
margin to it, you will
not see that cortical
rim. And this is
more of an aggressive
lesion here where
we cannot trace our
pencil around it. It's
infiltrated all the
way throughout. So
these are what more
aggressive lesions.
You won't be able to
trace your pencil
around it. So denying
lesions, I can trace
and outline the lesion
completely with a
pencil going around it.
A very aggressive
lesion, which you will
see with malignant
neoplasms. So this
is an example of a
malignant neoplasm.
An osteomyelitis has this
moth-y appearance to it.
And there's a very
permanent pattern,
so it's something
you need to know.
Permanent pattern again.
Different types of
peri-oxygen, you can
have benign peri
-oxygen, aggressive or
very aggressive peri
-oxygen reaction.
It's very
aggressive, so it
indicates that
there is a benign,
has a more solid
appearance.
As we get aggressive,
it has more of a
laminated and speculated
appearance, and then
the very aggressive has
this clavent triangle.
And because the bone
can't heal itself
quick enough as it lays
down the bone, that's
what has more of an
aggressive appearance,
as those lesions which
grow very quickly,
or infection which
happens very quickly.
So slow growing,
thick periostal
reaction, slow
growing, benign.
Once again, solid
periostal reaction.
This is that more
laminated appearance,
what we call onion
skin appearance to it.
It's because the
bone cannot produce
enough periostal
movement fast enough,
so it can't heal
fast enough, so you
get this laminated
appearance to it.
And the cognitive
triangle is the
same thing, where
you have these eye
growth of monocropies
fibers, which
are more aggressive,
sometimes type
lesion, a very
aggressive lesion.
And then lastly, we'll
talk about cosmos
triangle, which is
the most aggressive,
where it forms a
certain angle with the
periosteum, it forms
an angle because of
the tumor that's
happening underneath it.
So you have this
triangular type
formation to it.
A very aggressive
periostreaction seen
with malignant lesions.
So that was a whirlwind
tour of musculoskeletal
imaging. The
important stuff for
narrating or highlighting
red or things I
stressed that may be
pertinent for the exam.
This is an unfortunate
patient after a
motor vehicle accident
where their thoracic
cord completely,
their thoracic spine
completely dislocated.
So we have two thoracic.
We have the thoracic
The thoracic human
body is over here,
the thoracic over
here, we normally see
two thoracic human
bodies to answer their
posts to each other.
If you have
any questions,
please reach out.
Thanks so much.